welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and here we are with
another thor loving thunder trailer
video in our first one we covered a lot
of easter eggs and characters that would
be appearing in the movie such as jane
foster and also call the butcher huge
thank you for getting that training at
number two and everyone who supports
this channel is now my official friend
from work for this one though we're
going to be going over some of our
theories surrounding it as well as what
we think could be happening in the movie
i'm recording this tuesday morning when
the trailer has roughly been online
about 18 hours so if there's something
we don't cover then make sure you leave
it in the comments below as i'd love to
read it if you choose to run towards the
spoilers and not away from them then
this is the channel for you so make sure
you like it and subscribe for videos
like this almost every day without the
way thanks for clicking this now let's
get into gore love and thunder now
strangely the big bad of the film gore
is completely missing from the first
tease from poster christian pale has
done his batman disappearing trick and
after ties of him leaked online he
completely vanished from everything else
surrounding the movie in case you don't
know gore was devoted to the gods but
after his entire family died he realized
that they didn't actually care about the
people that worshiped them he then went
on a killing spree throughout the cosmos
brutally murdering every one of them
that he could we actually see a lot of
giants in the trailer that have been
slain and i think that this is teasing
the aftermath of his killing spree along
with the god that we'll see die in the
movie during the training montage we see
a giant skeletal figure slumped in
chains there's several mythology that
this could be such as prometheus and
also atlas prometheus was chained up and
every day birds would come in and eat
his intestines until he died and then
when the day started over he'd
regenerate his organs and the whole
thing would begin again atlas was a
titan who was forced to hold the world
up on his shoulders and both of these
were punishments put in place by zeus
who we know will be played by russell
crowe mt from new rockstars also said
that it could be a watcher but whatever
it is it's clearly been dropped in to
add this aesthetic of giant corpses in
the trailer later on just before thor
kisses the woman on the boat we can see
the body of a giant kraken behind him
and there's also falagar the behemoth
who shows up from the comics in the
source material this was thor's friend
who was a victim of gore i think that
he'll be going to zeus to try and warn
him about what's coming right after we
dropped our trailer breakdown the
official synopsis came out and in it we
learned what the plot of the movie is it
states that thor's journey for inner
peace is interrupted by gore's rampage
and after he recruits king valkyrie korg
and jane foster they head out to stop
him before it's too late in the trailer
we can catch them walking towards a
statue of zeus so i actually think that
the shot of jane at the end of the
teaser happens pretty early on in the
movie i'd love to see gore show up to
olympus and i think it would be such a
massive moment if we were introduced to
him through killing the king of the gods
watching the characters follow him on
his killing spree only to come face to
face with him doing this would be such a
cool way to show the character for the
first time and i can just imagine
christian bale making a massive entrance
with him now though is gonna need some
help to take him down there's actually a
shot in the trailer that looks like it
might have a missing character in it in
it we see thor and korg standing side by
side and it seems like there's an empty
space beside them that someone should be
filling up we've of course seen them
hiding characters for trailers such as
no way home and one of the vfx artists
that worked on the film recently spoke
to carter crew about the whole process
he said that you just hide the layer in
the render and send it off to be cut
into a trailer and i think that the
majority of the internet is well aware
that this is something marvel do a lot
now if it is indeed the case this opens
up a lot of possibilities over who this
could be i've seen deadpool mentioned
loki and medic on twitter said it's
probably either a drax or john cena
cameo yes some of a [ __ ] personally
though i think it could be beta ray bill
who were yet to meet in the mcu however
his head could be seen in thor ragnarok
on the grand masters tower and he's
definitely the kind of character you'd
call to take on gore in case you don't
know his home was destroyed by serta who
also appeared in ragnarok and his people
the korbonites no not them they chose
him to be their champion lacing him with
cybernetic parts he became the most
powerful of the race and he's also used
stormbreaker which would fit perfectly
with this movie as we know that munir is
coming back and the fact that jane
foster is going to be a version of thor
in the film also makes me think that
they might bring bill in it as well when
we look at what the mcu is doing with
phase 4 they actually seem to be
bringing in alternative versions of
established characters and this can be
seen across a number of films and shows
we of course had loki which had loki
lady loki kid loki all loki kata loki
bosov loki vote loki and so on and so on
no way home had the three spider-men
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is going to have multiple
versions of him and we now have thor
love and thunder with jane becoming a
version of thor as well it makes me
think that they might bring in other
versions of the character and this would
be the perfect way to debut beta ray
bill in the trailer thor is also wearing
his thunderstrike outfit and he actually
ended up donning this after another thor
called eric masterson emerged on the
scene just feels like phase 4 in general
is bringing variations on what we
already know and i'd love to see that
carried across in this movie too how she
got the hammer back together we don't
know but i think that after hella
smashed it that the pieces would have
remained behind the material used to
craft it of course was enchanted by odin
who made it so that you had to be worthy
in order to lift it therefore i think
that the pieces would have just stayed
on the ground where hella smashed it
because nothing would be able to lift
them the side of this was actually at
tonesberg which has appeared at several
points in the mcu it was where the frost
giants invaded at the beginning of thor
and then showed up at the start of
captain america the first avenger this
was the hiding place of the tesseract
which at the red skull ended up storming
it was also the place where odin died
and before he passed he told loki and
thor that it was home so ternsburg is
pretty important and it's nice to see
that it's now thriving and running to us
i think that this place might get
attacked by god's forces who could
potentially be the brood they've been in
the comics for a long time and are
absolutely terrifying no 100 percent of
it's them but the creatures behind jane
and thor do look quite similar this also
looks like tonesburg burning in the
background which may end up being the
fire that thor walks through at the
start i kind of feel like they're gonna
attack and that's when thor and co will
learn of course plan and they'll head
out to try and warn everyone they can
now as you come to know the best easter
eggs are often the ones that you leave
in the comments below i kind of want to
go over some of the other ones that i
missed in the trailer breakdown which
you spotted because hey you're probably
better at this than i am although we
spot the avengers logo on the cap that
thor was wearing whilst training we
didn't notice that this is actually a
note of the 1987 film adventures in
babysitting this is scene in that where
vincent de nofrio is mistaken for thor
and he's pretty much wearing the exact
same style of clothes that thor is
wearing in the new teaser it's also the
running scene at the start in which we
see his classic costume at one point i
really love this detail but we didn't
notice that the kid who starts up the
scene might actually be chris
hemsworth's son though this isn't
confirmed when the movie was being
filmed chris dropped a post on his
instagram of the pair on set together so
i i think it makes sense that they'd
have him come in to play a young version
of the character lastly is the cocktail
sign on the boat that we see leaving you
asgard i did notice this but i had no
idea that it's actually the cocktails
and dream sign from the tom cruise movie
cocktail huge thank you for everyone who
dropped that in the comments as i've
never actually seen the movie and i
guess that's pretty much all you need to
know about this movie channel however as
a thank you i'm gonna give you an
exclusive leaked image of tom cruise and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness to end the video with drum roll
please
[Music]
hey we have a laugh we have a laugh at
the channel don't we that's for everyone
who said le shawna lynch in the doctor
strange trailer was actually tom cruise
as superior iron man you punk i got you
sucker but hey thanks i guess probably
need to stop being nicer to you guys and
i i'm just playing you know i love you
really and thanks again so much for
getting us trending the love you show
the channel really means so much and i'm
glad that you can have as much fun with
it as we do even if i like to play a
prank on you from time to time bloody
tom cruise and doctor strange
but anyway that's the trailer that's
another joke by the way and i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
teaser we're running competition right
now and giving away three more copies of
spider-man now a home on the 15th of may
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer we pick the
comments at random and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out either our breakdown and moonlight
episode 4 or the thor trailer which will
be linked on screen right now a lot of
fun with both videos so yeah definitely
go check it out and let's just have a
nice relaxing enjoyable week watching
marvel stuff thank you very much for
sticking with me i'll see you next time
take care yourself peace